chrome developer tools are extremely
helpful for web developers
and i think all web developers should
have an understanding of what they can
do
nabhit who teaches this course is very
experienced and he will teach you
everything you need to know about them
in this course we will have a look at uh
chrome developer tools which you can go
from
zeros more tools and developer tools so
so once you click on it the developer
tools open
right and so in this
course we will talk about a look at each
of these tabs what does what do we do
with it and elements one
what do we do in source one what do we
do in network one
console memory performance and write our
security so all of these steps
and then we'll try to make sure that we
understand their basics
and uh once you're done with the course
so that you are very pretty much
comfortable with it so without wasting
for the most time
let's get going and let's start with the
basics
so in this uh first lesson
let's try to get comfortable of how do
we
move around the chrome developer tool
how do we
you know what lies where and few other
things
so how do you how can you open this is
you what you can do is you can click on
this three
dots more tools and developer tools
that's one of the way which is ctrl
shift i
also the shortcut in mac you can have
command shift i or
um it depends for us f12 also works
right so once you click on it the
the developer console opens
and if you look at the
the overall getup of this it is as of
now dark
what you can do is you click on this
icon gear one
okay let me make it bigger yes
and you can change the theme from dark
to light
right for example if i make it light it
needs a reload okay so what i will do is
let me just uh maybe reload it again
and then i just press ctrl shift i
and now it is a light theme right
and then you can have a layout also
clover format you can also have
some default settings for your record
network log whether you want to
whatever the activity is going on in the
network you want to record that
so or you want to enable javascript auto
completion so these are the
few of the settings which you can do
right how much indentation you want
and then workspace is something you can
add the folders
for example whichever project you are
working in you can add it here and you
can
change the code in the chrome developer
console only
this tool also i will show that in
in the relevant section and then there
are some experimental features
which are always there because they are
not finalized and they are not really
but you can still
uh they can you know work on them and
then you have ignore list anything which
you want to
speak from let's say whenever a website
load you want to
skip some scripts so you can add those
and accordingly you have devices
because you can also you know customize
that you can also check how your website
how do your
the application will look and feel like
on different
devices this is where you can set right
throttling is like for example
uh let's say your app or website is
going to be open on a
on some locations where your download
and upload speed will be less
so you can have a profile name you can
you know you can provide the download
speed upload speed latency and
you can check how does your application
will behave so you can accordingly
you know find in your applications then
you have the shortcuts
which will talk about you know we have
every shortcut here
so if you want you can you know people
who are more fond of using a
keyboard and they can these use
check the shortcuts and uh
full lists will be found here okay so
so that's that's bit about it's it's
it's
color settings and all right and uh
now if you look at this screen right
this is
these are the different view areas or
different tabs which are available
for example under elements tab you can
have
your html right then under source code
it will load the
different source codes of the file okay
console where you can do some stuff
where you can write your own javascript
code
network is like whatever files were
loaded whatever ajax requests were sent
all those things can be recorded here
performance is basically you want to
check how your
overall website is doing
memory and then applications this is
something this browser also comes up
with its
local storage so local storage is it
will remain only till the time the
browser is open
session storage will be released you
know there even if you close and reload
again
and indexeddb are not we'll cover these
in detail
then you see this security lighthouse
and these are other customers
okay and and on the right hand side
based on different tabs
you can have different views for example
elements you can have your css
right for source you can have your
source controller
this is your console you can close it
also
right and so every tab every view
has its own corresponding things
which will help you in troubleshooting
right so that's how you normally
basically
uh not troubleshoot things not basically
this is a this is a single stop shop for
you to troubleshoot
your website related issues so i think
at least we now understand okay what it
is
okay one more thing i forgot is if you
click here
as of now i have kept it as a separate
one
i can add it directly inside the window
so for example if i say dock to the
right
so it will automatically open right
and if i say dock below so it goes to
the bottom and if i
say dock left depends on individual to
individual how you are
comfortable with right and then
also you can change your device tool
this is like how this view will look on
a
mobile moto g4 galaxy so these devices i
hope you remember
these are coming from
this devices okay so
you can check here only that how will
your
web app will behave in under different
devices
okay and you can click here and then if
you click again these three dots
you can you can have a kind of uh
more tools for example apart from these
tabs you can have these different types
which is like something related to
sensors
network conditions you know right and
then you can also open the shortcuts
from here the same thing happens
right and and you can have a
run command which is like whatever
operations you will see we are
performing here we can
do it do i just shortcut that
let's say you want to show the network
so you click here so it'll
automatically go to the network right so
this is like um you know terminal type
kind of a thing
console drawer is like this one where
you can write your own code
right and uh search as if in case you
want to find something that's a global
source
okay so that's bit about uh our our
console
that at a very high level what how it is
briefly organized
now what we will do is we will create a
small project
which is like which will have a small
html file a very basic one
and a javascript file and a style
because we will make we'll see how do we
troubleshoot different things
using this chrome developer so moving on
let's first now create our small website
not a website small page which includes
all three different types of files
okay so we have created a very simple
page
which is uh which is loading two files
one is a style sheet
style dot css now there is a my file js
all it does is it has an h1 element some
list basic one
then click below to begin your journey
and then it has a button right and
button we have this event
okay so this is pretty straightforward
one there's nothing
in frenzy right and when we say that
okay
they said for what we have in our css
first is
uh uh we have is a once
we have as a body body tag
always we have to find that this has to
be the color let me just
bring it here so now you can see that
for body we are saying background is
this
s1 has to be of this color paragraph has
to be this
if i hover over the list over over the
list
the background color should become red
for this
right and in javascript
all i'm saying is on click you do alert
your update uh
right what i am using to run this local
server is
basically what we call it as a live
server
you can add it as an extension as a
add-on to your vs code
right and then you can also run it
so if you look here so here you can go
to live
server this is the library
which i have installed and in case you
want to
run it all you need to do is ctrl shift
e
and do a live server also okay so now
maybe let's look at this so this is how
our
website not a very great one right
it's a very uh basic one and but
this will help us and and in
understanding how do we troubleshoot
things how do we debug things
and if we look at this the hover is also
taking effect
right to our website which we want to
troubleshoot as set
so let's now open our console
okay and let me just reload it so that
everything becomes clear so if i just
reload it
so now if you look here it network it
shows what all files are loaded
these two are others are web server
let's just ignore it so our focus right
now is this elements
okay so what this does is it shows the
complete html file
for uh whatever is displayed for example
body whichever whichever tag you will
click on
that will get selected for example body
this is h1
this is ul under this we have list
right so it's basically this is m and if
you look at on the right side
it it automatically selects what all
what all css is applicable for example
style css one background color is this
text line is centered
there can be many multiple css but some
of it will be applied to your element
how do we find out that so what you can
do is go to this computed one
right and now you can see that for this
body
the pending is this border margin
and then you can see clearly the color
right what is the background color
and you can also see from where it is
coming right because there can be
multiple side sheets
from where they are coming and some are
inherited
for example if i just click here these
are all
the inherited one okay and these are all
coming from the style sheets the basic
one which is inserted
okay and so we now
and then we also have something like
the rendered fonts and all the details
now for example what if you want to
select any of it
so what you can do is you click here and
let's say i want to see what is
happening with learn
so learn is getting selected which is a
lie right
and the style is here is there's only
text line which is center
and that is coming from body not from
every time
right and for example if i want to see
a h1 so for h1 the color is coming from
set right and what i can do is
if i go here and if i click here
if i want to see how it will look like
if i change it
so for example i can make it red this
and i can you know increase degrees
gradients colors everything so whatever
you want to do you can do that from
there
if you want to change the change of
alignment right you can let me make it
like this so that
i want to make it as left line
right so you can see how it looks right
let's just keep it centered let's say i
want to have
a font size as
size of
30 pixels so now it is increase 46 and
then also it is increased so you can
play around with its style
right and then for example if i
go to accessibility i can also see this
another key from where it is coming
and what others are here okay
so that's how basically you can
check what all styles are assigned to it
and and how you can modify and try
changing them
now let's say that this one i want to
modify the text also so what you can do
is
do a right click go to edit as html i
say let me just slide it in a bit
right and i can just see how it looks
like
right what if i want to see that how do
this this node i can select it
go to copy and copy
js path and then if you go to console
and you can write here this control v
you can see it is already selecting this
right
and uh we will cover console in detail
but
this is how you select this element okay
now
going back again to elements and if i
select this
right and if i right click this again
and i say copy copy styles
then all the css which is applied to
uh this h1 element
will be shown copied you can see here
this caller is this text line everything
is
copied right and let me just close it
and for example if you have to
you know inspect this element how you
can do is do a right click
and say inspect element which is like
ctrl shift i right and it again open the
same thing
right it is already selected so
now let's let's so we now understood
okay this is how you can
because the overall this is nothing but
everything is at the end is an html
tag so that's how you work with them now
for example let's
let's look at uh this unordered list
which has these elements right
so what i can do is let's say if i want
to add one more list
so i can do a copy or i can delete
directly do a duplicate so you can see
there is one more at it
right i can also do a
height element and this is hidden
right you can see this is hidden but the
space is this is it
right and uh what if
uh now if you must be noticing that
if i hover over this it is
it is turning into red right and if i go
here and look into style of css and
resource but we'll go into source
once into the next lesson but for time
being why it becomes red
is because i have i have a css ally
to colon power as background
right and how do we trigger this is what
you can do is for example
this is the element which is selected i
don't need to cover it right i need to
over it to trigger this but another way
out is
you can click here right with this as
selected you can trigger
this element straight over and now when
that state is reached you can see that
how it is becoming
red background color is a line
and if i go here this also you will see
that okay this is the reason
the style daughter says that it is
becoming red
correct so that's how basically uh
you are able to uh trigger different
uh stuff right
so now so we see how do we
trigger this how do we edit an element
and in fact you can add also once you
say
if i just say add it as html right
so you can add whatever you feel like
correct
and now let's say that you want to add a
you want to suppose let me first select
this
right so you can filter these properties
also
you can say that where is textview so
you can filter those
so text align you can clearly see those
those those filters you can apply
right and same goes for computed one
also
here also you can have a list and it
will already filter place one list
right and then you can also
kind of uh you can add your class also
for example
if i want to add a new class here i can
add
any new class here so that is it right
so so that's how basically and you can
see the color is also change
right so you can
play around with the styles you can
debug it you can check from where it is
coming
you can edit it right and
you can also what you can do is you can
also
delete stuff you can hide stuff also
okay one more thing what you can do is
for example
i want to see what part of my
css and all those stuff is being used
right
so for that what you can do is you can
have
a click on control shift e you can open
uh coverage show coverage
okay and if i just click on reload
right then it tells me that
okay in my style these these parts are
covered
let me just uh maybe what i will do is
let me modify something maybe i can have
something like uh not this we cannot
be one let's add something like p1 right
and just save and then we see in
style.css right
me just
do it again this is from the command
palette also you can go from here also
run command ctrl shift e
and i use it should be concept right you
can
then here if i double click this right
yes if i i don't know what this does not
work
but if i double click this file i can
see that my body these all parts have
been used but li
has has not been as well as p1 hasn't
been but if i just say
move here this turns its blue right why
it has been used
so in our elements tab as of now
what we learned about was that
how do we select an element how do we
add up
different classes right how do we
kind of
filter them how do we see which
which which style is added to which
element how can we
basically copy that id
where which that elements refers to
we can copy the styles as well as you
can
so that's that's bit about our elements
now in our next chapter or video
we will move towards our sources tab
where we will understand about how how
do we handle the code how do we
you know let's say if i click here and
how do we this
this message is getting triggered for
example if i just say okay
now you need to troubleshoot it we'll
look at that okay
so now in this uh listen we will look at
uh
this source tab and before that
uh let us just look at quickly at the
core changes which i have done
rather than just simply having a you
know when you click on this
file button right rather than just
showing alert message
about format i have defined a function
nested call
to which i am for passing a variable my
account and it is returning its count
right and then again i am showing
another message
right so idea is to showcase you the
different features
of debugging using this
and for the timing let's just say that
uh let me just close this
and if i just click here you complete
one extra you complete seven exercises
now let's just try to troubleshoot it
that i want to see how it is happening
okay so for that what we will do is
first
if you press ctrl shift i you this panel
is opened
and it has three parts
one is on left hand side is a kind of a
hierarchy of your files
how they are placed then you have in the
center is the window where different
files will be opened
right it'll be like this and on right
side you see there is a different kind
of breakpoints breakfast
look at them we look at this so this is
how
it is things are organized right now
let's see that when i click on this
button it automatically run this code
and i know that this function is being
called
right so so how do i stop the code in
the debugger
so the first thing which i can do is i
can simply put a breakpoint
by clicking here if it turns blue it is
a
the breakpoint is active if you click
again it gets the bug
it's it get deleted or you can create a
breakpoint using
right click and add breakpoint for the
timing we'll just say
add breakpoint right and if i click here
what does it say pause then develop
right and the code has stopped
okay now let's just first look at these
three
these these some of these buttons this
one means you just
i want to execute it you don't want to
debug
this means you want to debug it but you
will you want to
step over each call for example if i
click here
it goes to next one it calls alert okay
now here yes here it is a function
called nested call where this my account
is
being passed so one thing which i can do
is either i want to go inside
debug this function or i just want to
skip over
so for example i want to skip over so
that's what this step over function does
and you are able to see this message all
right
and if i just say process that's okay
now
let's again look at it and let's see how
does this step in
support work so if i now click here
and it goes again here and i just want
to step over this
okay now i want to debug this so i go
inside this one f11
so it goes here right for example now i
feel that everything looks okay i don't
want to debug it i want to come out of
this
so that's where you have stepped right
so that's how you basically do this step
by step and then you can just simply say
click click on resume and everything is
done so these are the buttons basically
which you use to you know move to
towards different codes okay so now
since we have seen how how these
different uh
options are there right and now what you
can do is
that for example you can place multiple
breakpoint i can place a breakpoint here
here and here okay so
for example if i do this right now it
stops here
i say resume message is coming
and again it goes to here right and then
again step by step it will start it will
stop at every point every break point
and it will show me everything right but
let's say
you don't you said that okay this
breakpoint is okay rest i think a lot
okay i just want to proceed i don't want
to stop
right so what you can do is you you see
this there's a down arrow
the you just click on it and
you hold the mouse button right and then
you click on
the second option so it basically goes
through everything
so what it does is it basically uh
skips through rest of the break points
right so another option is
for example you don't have these
breakpoint you just surface breakpoint
and you say i want to debug
so it comes here but you don't want you
want to skip everything and you want to
directly
in the code to directly go here
just click here and do a
continue here that's it and first
message come line number three
and it stops so that's how you can
basically
skips through the the few lines and the
codes and you can directly go there
okay sometimes what you need to do is
for example you have executed everything
and you are at these somewhere in
between
but you want to restart it right you
want to go to the beginning and
start again this whole function so what
you can do is
uh go here on the call set to a restart
frame
right this is one way you can do it so
all i need to do is restart frame
and goes to the beginning right and it
starts again that's how
you basically
the starts execution of this function
and what you see here
is let's just focus on as of now on call
stack
so this is like in what order this this
function is being called for example
first is you see
there's a button in our index.html which
has on click event
which call this and that's where it
comes right
and this this is called as uh the trace
and you can also do a
right click copy stack trace so it
basically
what it does is you can see there's a
staff trace is copied
right and then you can basically
uh kind of uh move through your
you know check through troubleshoot your
issues using calls check that how the
calls have happened
and where probably an issue can lie
right
so let me just step over to the next
function and just show you how do you
check the variable value one is you can
see there is already available variable
value coming
my count is equal to 1 another way is
you can just
hover over it you will see this value or
you can just copy this variable you can
go here
it shows that another way is if you look
at this scope
there is a local scope where you see
this my account variable one
and you can modify it from here also
right
if you just double click you can modify
it very simple
right so let me just say okay okay
that's fine that's
that's okay okay so now we see one type
of a break point
there are multiple type of break points
which we will see
so one is the this is simple breakpoint
right
and there is if you do a right click for
example if i do a right click here
there's a conditional breakpoint so this
breakpoint will be triggered based on
certain condition it will not be
triggered like always so why what i can
do is
if my count is equal to seven
right double seven then only trigger it
and i know that one is
it will be one here then it will call
this method nested calls one plus six is
seven it will get triggered
and now you can see this that is yellow
orange right orange is kind of yellow
that it will be like conditional so if i
just click here
and let me just remove this
so now it stops here because my account
value is 7
right now if i edit it right click
edit i say this value is 6 then only
stop
and now if i click here it doesn't stop
so which is the way we want them to be
right so that's how these are
conditional breakpoints one is a simple
breakpoint
another is a breakpoint is a dom break
point
right for example let me just
first do one thing
just move this let me just uh
this is a list under which we have this
element i'm just copying it
right and copying the path okay
and what i will do is if you click on
this button
i will remove this entry the the first
one right
so what i will do is i will have
something like this
dot remove method
okay so i'm selecting it and then remove
method
is there if you look at this source this
is a document.queryselector select this
path this element
and then remove it if i click this
button right but before that i want that
in case anything happens to this list
[Music]
i should have a breakpoint triggered so
what i can do is first let me delete
this
or i can disable also i click disable it
is disabled
right and this is a different one and if
i can
disable blue one it will be light blue
so these are all disabled points if i
enable it
right then they become enabled and i can
i can see these two breakpoints under
this i can also enable disable from h
okay so now let me disable them what i
will do
is i say that in case this unordered
list which is this complete
break on subtree modification so if in
case
anything under this tree modifies you
break you stop
or in case any attribute modifies then
you stop in case there is a node removal
then also you stop so i say substring
modification
so it becomes blue right dom break point
right
so if you go here you can see there's a
dom break point in everyone
now if i click here you completed one
exercise
now it stops automatically and you can
see that paused on subtree modification
you will descendant li removed
automatically okay so this is the dom
break point if i just say
okay you can see this
this is already deleted
okay now sometimes you want that
whenever you click this button
what is happening which event what is
mouse click event what is happening can
i
listen to this event and can i have
trigger a breakpoint
yes so if you look here there's an even
listener breakpoint
and under it you have different things
different events any mission canvas for
us it is
we'll take mouse we'll say click so
whenever i click
let it trigger a breakpoint so if i just
click here
so it triggers a breakpoint
automatically it says this button type
on click event and
if i just execute it then it also
automatically trigger my other
breakpoints
right so that's how it basically
triggers it
let me just first delete all these
and show you one more thing
break on and subtree okay so another
thing is
basically is for example um
what you want is that you want to
trigger a breakpoint when this function
is called
nested and you don't know when it will
be called but it is globally available
because i have
upload unloaded this file by index.html
so what i can do in control is
you can say debug nested call
okay whenever this is called you debug
it so i just click here
and
you see it automatically gets triggered
nested call i did not put any breakpoint
it got triggered automatically right
paused on debug function it
automatically tells you that okay this
is
how things are right okay
good let me just reload it because the
entries are deleted right
and now let's see that
another thing which i really have not
seen is you can also modify these code
for example i can say
my account is equal to two and press
save simple press save
and if i click here you can see
you completed two exercise the value
gets modified right
but if i just do a refresh
and you see this value is lost right
so there are two ways around it right
how do you preserve these changes okay
so what you can do is
one way is you say that you click on
this file system
right and you add your chrome folder
right this one from developer tools
folder
to the workspace you see allow
and now whatever changes you will make
here so let me just close all
in whatever changes you make for example
i make it to two
i make it completed one two three
right and uh here also i write something
and i press save
so whatever changes you make here right
you can see them
that they will automatically are let me
just read this
breakpoint that one two three
eight everything is getting reflected
right and if you look at
if you just press the refresh also still
the changes are still right why because
the code is
it is directly modifying your file
system if you look at this
does this here so you can actually in
fact modify everything
the developer console so anything
everything you can modify
right and uh one important other thing
which i wanted to
showcase is uh one is this
not one let's look at this snippet right
so in case you want to store this
code in the browser right so what you
can do is
you click here you know you go to here
snippets
okay let me go back again snippets
and then you click on new snippet and
you paste your code or press save right
or you can do a right click
rename my samples right
and uh maybe we just want to
store this for example console.log
hello right and now you want to run it
so what you can do is either you can
press ctrl enter
right or it will console log hello
right or you can come here and run this
so these are like multiple snippets
you can store for uh
for your reference in the browsers okay
then for example if i go back again to
file system
right and if i go here let me close this
and let's say if i change this right
and i have changed this also
right or in fact i added another
function also
let's just assume right i want to see
what all changes i have done right now
without before saving
so what you can do is you can go from
here
more tools and changes
you can clearly see in function there is
you have added this
then you added this then you add
so it also tracks those also right so
basically
at any point of time you are
you are checking you know making some
changes trying to check what have you
done
so you can use this changes tab also
right
now let's say that i want to remove it
let me
remove this folder from workspace
so let's say that rather than having
the whole workspace here i just want to
make some changes try out things
and let those changes persist also when
i reload and if i later
want it to merge with my changes i'll do
it so what you can do is
for example if i just go to page
and i want to see what happens if my
account is three
and i just press save and if i just
refresh
my account is again two right how do i
make sure those my temporary changes
persist
so for that what you can do is go to our
rights
select the folder if i
select chrome developer tools and i say
allow
right now if i just say
maybe three right
and uh now
because now it is done with violet so
right now
if i just press refresh
right so it is now three if i just
change it to
five right and
you know hold on and i press save
and uh if i just press refresh my count
is five but if you look at the back end
code
it is still two so how it is doing is
it is a override folder which it creates
inside this right where you can see my
account file
okay so that is normally which you can
use to
to sometimes check your chummy changes
and then
uh kind of uh
if you think they are okay then you can
immerse them
so so this is we have come to this
source
tab and of the things right end of the
lesson
where we have looked at trace probes
breakpoint
listeners source codes how do we debug
and operate so now without wasting for
the most time
let's move on to the next lesson which
is related to the next tab which is
console
and then you might look into network
performance certification
also hello everyone
in our previous lessons we have covered
elements sources and now in this
we will plan to cover console so
like sources console is also very
important
so this is like uh you know apple where
you can write your javascript code you
can
run it you can you can make you can
check how it looks
right and primarily in console normally
for example
uh let's look at our code so so normally
developers what they do is they they
kind of log some stuff
when something is done right for example
here it is console.log is being used
right
let's just look at it what it does so
for example if in sources you go
you will see console.log is being logged
in in nested call which is being called
an on click event
let me just click here okay okay
and this is done so but what happens so
anything
which a developer wants to process is or
wants to log
is logged in if you look at here there
are four messages
so this is the one which was which came
from our fees
completed one two three nested call if
we look at here
this is the same right and so that these
you know developers can have different
kind of login messages
and on left hand side what you see is
this four messages is like for
everything
then in case you want to see only errors
you can use this filter
warnings info right whatever we have
logged and user messages if
right and in user messages these are
these are like
uh the locations from where those
messages are coming for example my file
dot
ds is one message which is coming from
here
and another message is coming from live
load so these are the five different
ways to see the message
right and you can if you want to clear
it you can clear it using clear console
and if you want to increase the size
just control
okay and in case you want to filter it
you can filter that also for example if
i just refresh
right and i click here
so you see there are two messages and if
i want to filter for a click
only click will come if i just say rdea
then
those will get filtered all right and
then
then that that's how basically the whole
uh logging happens and you can view
those logs
now you can also preserve the logs
in which there is a reload or something
right if i just hit reserve log
and if i do an f5 right you will see
that this log is
still there it's the previous one
and similarly there are other options
while for example you can log stm
in the the those xhr hx request also
right and you can do enable auto
complete from history also
right so let's just try to
while we are in console let's try to
look at how does
this console okay so for example if you
just want to
log any messages you just press console
and you will see what all different
methods are available for example i just
press enter
so there is error info log one in count
there
and number of error in the method which
are available that's how you can which
you can
use in your code to put kind of a
breakpoint not breakpoints the log
checkpoints in your case for example if
you just want to log a message
to the console you can just say arrow
one two three and it is locked hello one
two three
simple and uh for example let's say
there's a error there's an array not
error
area of salary right and
uh which is like which has objects so
it's like
month as uh exact
and uh salary
and the thousands okay let's say there
is this one object
and then there is another then there is
another so there are this area of three
objects now you want to log them so one
way
you just say console.log
celery right it will just lock this very
object and you have to
drill down to right another way is to
make it more
meaningful and you know beautiful is
console.table and you just say salary
so you see it has index is one column
month and salary so it's just
much better readable and all right
and now for example um so so you want
some
let's say let me just clear it so one
way of clearing is this
ctrl l another way is console
dot clear so it clears it
uh due to preserve block okay yeah
so once again let me just do this
and now we run this console.clear so it
clears it right
now let's see that okay in case we want
to log a message which is an
error how would it look like we want it
to stand out so what i will do is
say console.log console.error
test error
it gets shown in red if you say console
dot
warning just
maybe let's say
test walking
you have it in yellow so in case if you
click here it will show that test
running
you click here it shows testers if you
click here it shows everything in the
file using the file right it is
mentioning it as others because we are
using this
right and then what you can do is uh
once you have an error let's say
sometimes uh
you want to log a certain set of
messages in a group let's say
you have one function call you want to
log that messages under one function
group and then there's another function
then you want to lock those messages
how do you do that so what you do is you
say control dot
group
group was let's say g1
right and then you say console dot
log hello i'm
imagining i'm inside a function so
console.error
[Music]
[Music]
these are thrown from one function okay
and i'm logging it as under g1 function
name let's say there is another one
which is like g2
right and that's how those are
drawn so whatever you press enter you
see this
so there are two groups g1 g1 has yellow
hello and error right so you can use
these
what if i let's say let me do that what
if i just
use this right and
i want to log that let me close this
style
that
will just so it will say
on click event right and
i just say group end right
and let's not have it as console we say
console.log
and we say console dot
error so we are logging two messages
just for our tracking
and now what i will do is in case this
function is also call
we will log that also right and then we
say
and this key right and i just press save
and because it is live server
so now as of now the clear everything is
clear right if i click here
why there is alert console also
let me
yeah you remember why there is an alert
because
the changes are coming from this right
so let's just remove it and delete all
our rights because there is an override
and now if i just press this button
and now you see this red one shows one
error one warning
and one okay so we're going to go to
this you see on click event
then you have you completed one x one
two three exercise
and then you say nested call then there
is this
right and if you look here
why it is you know kind of not closed
here is because
if you look in the code
this call is before this call so what i
can do is
maybe i can say it like this
right you call it let's just see it as a
group complete one so if i now click
here
so you see there are two groups so
that's how we use this
okay i think uh one thing is remaining
related to controller
which is console. assert okay so that's
like
how do we do is let's say we have
let's let's say we have variable a is
equal to
10 and where b is equal to 20
right so now what you see is like
that we want to say that
c is equal to b
is a is less than
10 a is less than b
right it has these messages so now how
you can use
console dot
basically you want to pass the condition
first condition is
b a is less than b okay
and then what do you say is that
what is the data you say my data is a
comma
b right
comma c
right and if this and you just execute
it right
and if a is less than b this result
condition is true which is okay and if
it relates this
assertion field because a is not greater
than b so it logs the data also
clear so it's like you are making some
version is less than b with this data if
this assertion fails
which in this case it has failed so now
you can have
little option so you can use this
console as a rebel
you can code anything even if let's say
i want to
remove this for example this one right
what i will do is i'll say
copy js path i can try it here only
i can say dot
right same way if you want to
copy this path and you want to see what
all methods are there you just press
start
and you can see whether it is click and
all and everything in here also you can
have
i'm just taking an example so that is
also one
so that's what we learn in this lesson
so
maybe now we have understood fairly well
elements sources
console and it's like a playground for
us
and we can interact with the on the code
also
in fact we can modify the values also
during debugging
now next we'll look at networks then
we'll look at
applications and the other tabs
so now we have understood about elements
source console time now to understand
and talk about
networks
so normally what happened is so let me
just clear everything and just do a
refresh
and now if you look at this when i when
any website
anything which loads there are set of
files which are uploaded so you can see
there is a style.css my file there is a
web socket because of
live server there is a ui file on this
you can ignore so these are the
different files which are loaded
and so you can look at them for example
if you look at click on this
it tells you what is the request it is
loading this
what is the method get method status is
green okay
what was the response header this was a
header
and then you can check in response also
those code
right and it can tell you what initiated
it
right and it also shows you how much
time it took to load for example which
you can see here also in the waterfall
model
right and the status also tells us that
what is the status that is like 200
means
everything is working fine right in case
you want to filter certain
queries or certain files you want to see
whether they are loaded or not
you can for example filter it here using
my or whatever filter you define for
example if i say
i want gs files or js files another way
of js
file to be filtered is this one you see
all js
cs1 css1 xhr is where you mix ajax since
we don't have any
so that's why you don't see it but
otherwise you know you can have these
filters and if you want you can write
data url also
as well as if you want you can block
certain requests also for example if you
right click here you say block request
then it will come on the block okay
and then if if you do a right click you
can
save these requests also there's another
function which is to
which is like a recording network log
stop and start
for example if i just stop it and i just
say refresh
right then it will not uh log let me
just clear it
so if i just say refresh you can see
there is no log coming because i have
stopped network logging
and if i just enable it and do a refresh
you can see this
so where it is used is when normally
what happen is
your front end interacts with the back
end then you make those xhr requests
and those requests are normally you can
track them here
what requests are made for example let's
just uh maybe
let's open the site name or to our
rd right and if i open this right and
i do a reload let me do a reload
and now you can see there are so many
requests being sent right
so how do i filter so let's say i want
to see what are the ajax requests and
so in this case i don't see any what are
the javascript files these are the
javascript files
because i need to debug and i might need
to choose them right
what are the css files you can see that
the bootstrap so
clearly it is using bootstrap you know
are there any images
yes there are many images anything media
no
phones yes these are talk anything yes
this is a one
web socket sending there are no web
servers and and similarly
and you see this console also these
error messages
shows you something that okay there is
some error some some file is missing or
some font is missing
right let's say if i just click here and
i
say reference library
okay and if i just say
let me just keep it all and let me just
clear it okay
and let's see what if i want to click
this
so now we can see there is a request
which is being sent
and if i just do an x hr there's nothing
there is if you just open it it will
tell you what kind of
requests have gone for example this css
one which responds
anything javascript rated and all those
stuff so basically you can drag and in
case if you look at this request
this request was sent to this place
okay and what was the response
the same thing whatever you see here is
you can see those values
so that's how normally we use networks
is to check
whatever is being ordered is there any
file which is missing
is there is there any call
which is not going through that's how
which he uses for troubleshooting
so now in our next lesson what we'll do
is we'll we'll go through
first as applications and then we'll go
through other tabs
so we have seen
element source console tab and network
tab so far
i think now to talk about application
tab so this is
uh the place where you actually see what
local data is stored by the page
for example local storage is like uh if
you open one
session here and i open the same thing
in next tab
then the data has the data needs to be
shared that is the local storage
but as soon as you open the tab a
session is open and any data you want to
just save for that session
is stored in session storage this web
sql db are typically
in browser databases right the light one
cookies is what all any cookies which
are stored by the website you see that
then you have cash you know so what we
will see is how do we create this local
storage or how do we read it
and uh one way for this is that
i write it here but since we now
understood what is console
so we will actually you know do it
interactively in console
for example if i click here i go to
console
and we have a global upgrade local
storage
and we will say local storage or set
item uh name let's say i want to store
the name
right name is the browser
okay and i let's say i want to store the
same name
in session storage
okay so now if you go to
the application tab you will see there
is a name in a feed
and there is name evaluates is stored
like a key value
and good thing is you can filter also
you can delete a value also
you can delete all right and in case you
want to read it
that is also not very that's also very
straightforward
right so all you need to do is do
get item then in the name in the
in the value you pass the p
[Music]
so i want to see what is the name of it
right and same you will go for this
and you can delete also by using
the move item so local storage remove
right on the bead
and if you see here this is born but
session is still there
right so let me just store again the
local one because i want to show you
something
okay so now we have both named
here as well as here let's see what
happens if i just
copy this open a new one
right and if i open uh
the window you will see here this local
storage is there
but session storage is not all right
and in case you want for example you can
clear it from here if i say
local storage clear all and if you see
here and you go to local storage it is
like a
data which is shared across multiple
tabs
and session is local to it
so maybe let me open one one more
one more application so that you can see
if we have any cookie or not
let me just say ctrl shift i
okay and
you will see here in under application
there are
cookies right which is nothing but name
value here
right and youtube this is like another
one from where which we are getting the
cookies right
does it have any local storage yes it
has these keyboard values
storing locally like this one frequency
and youtube also locally some data
electrical youtube
and then there is session storage
nothing in related to session storage
yes in youtube it has some session
storage data
so so that's how normally when you want
to
understand is there any data which is
locally stored
or anything what value in it
and you can interact with that using it
so i hope it makes sense
and in our next video we'll cover the
next tab
okay so in our previous uh
previous lessons whatever you call them
we have understood elements sources
console
network as well as applications now i
think it makes sense to club
performance as well as lighthouse so
the overall intention is to you know
study your website in
all the specific perspectives whether it
is from accessibility
uh performance wise or how it will be to
the user
so first let's start with lighthouse and
all you need to do is what categories
you want to check where i want to check
its performance
progressive web web it is not there but
let it be able to run those text also
seo so i want accessibility i want and
device i
want to check is let's say mobile and
all you need to do is just generate
report
so it will kind of do an audit of this
report right
so you can see on the left hand side uh
there is uh there is a
mobile it is trying to load on that
mobile console mobile the demo one it is
trying to load on that
and now hopefully we will get our report
in terms of these categories you can see
our website is following 100 best
practices although one page
performance wise there is 62 percent and
uh
okay very good what i forgot to mention
since we have not used in cognitive mode
the chrome extension which we have have
impacted it
right so let's do this one more time yes
so maybe we go to this and
then i open again the same way
the lighthouse and i say generator board
everything same options
ah because now you can see because it is
a very simple single page
i was like why in performance it is bad
because there were
extensions there but now it is hundred
which is what best practice is under one
facebook
as cos we are down accessibility also
not good now if you scroll down
you will see matrix wise time to
interactive and everything is green
green
green
there is a trace and there is a
accessibility issues
right bathroom and forward london do not
have a
sufficient contrast ratio then it tells
you
the different options of how do we fix
it right or
maybe on seo also it tells you there is
no meta tag yes we had not provided it
all these things so that is one aspect
it tells you
talks about how your website is what is
how does
what are its how does it rate from
different parameters now let's say i
want to
measure this performance if i do some
actions right so if i just say
record and i just say start i
just want to click on these things three
four times right
and then i say stop so it will also
record during that time however website
is behaving
good thing is you can set the the
network also whether
it is 3g 4g we have not set any you can
set what kind of a cpu also
and if you look at it there are three
parts to it one is fps frame per second
and it is all good which is very good
because there is no less of a frames
there is no frame drop
cpu utilization is also good not much
and it was also
so if you look at here the frames
there's almost
it's just one frame per second item
frame it's all green right it's good so
nothing bad
and if you just scroll up you will see
where your time is being most of the
time it's applies in scripting
rendering printing primarily it is
scripting because uh
we are clicking this button there are
logics being run right
and you can have this uh um
there's not much here put them up not
much here
even also is empty okay good because our
website is a very basic one so it
doesn't have that
let's do one more thing let's let's open
google.com
okay and uh what we'll do is we'll
delete this
and we'll declase
and then we say generator report on
google.com and we'll see
do we have any issues or anything issue
related to google.com you can access any
site
across these parameters and let's see
how it behaves with
google
and it also provides you some tips also
how you can increase your little low
time and you know can
improve your performance so let's see
what score does google gets actually
wow performance wise amazing
so i will say time to interact total
blocking time
what you can do is because it might have
i have already labeled a site here so
you can
do multiple you can generate this report
multiple time and
to come up at a certain decision and i
think
uh removable news so it tells you where
there is someone new javascript
accessibility-wise it is very good
whatever is small changes it tells you
and then best practices there is some
form size or register
those you can do pw it's not a pwa
search engine
so so there is always a room for
improvement
that's that's very important so
lighthouse and performance is what will
be useful so in our next one we will
i like to look at security
and memory and then that will be like
our end of the
course
so in this last lesson we'll talk about
briefly about
memory and security and in case you see
don't see these tabs you can click here
and go to more tools and you can choose
from here
so typically security is like what kind
of certificates
our site has since it is not secured
it doesn't use https it is http
that's why you see this right for
example if i open
google.com right and
uh then i see
this security tab let's just uh
let it open yeah
so now you will see here is a little
lower little bit slower
so it is a security green and you can
also see the certificate also what
certificate is using
right and you can download it so and all
the details are there
so that's the importance of this site
right that's important this secure data
you can
view the certificates settings resources
everything is secured or not
right and here it clearly shows it is
non-secure
right so now uh
so we understand what happens in secure
freedom
let's maybe go to memory so there what
happens is
because this whole website contains so
many javascript objects
right so those objections things how
much memory they are occupying how much
this storm actually is occupying your
memory
what what are the tasks of deck so those
things we can look here so what you can
do is you click here
you go to this memory tab you click here
on take snapshot
and then you just press refresh
this number is increasing right so this
increase is actually basically building
the snapshots
and okay so here you now see all the
relevant objects
window document time saying shadow size
is the current
of memory size which has been occupied
by the
object series and strings and retained
is in case they're released how much of
it can be recovered and distance is
typically
more from like you know you store
different memory
areas one is linked to two two is linked
to two so how far those nodes are
distant
and if i search of this in daw
so here i don't see any uh detached node
that anodes are like for example if you
have a tree
and then that tree has its leave nodes
and if you delete the leaf nodes i are
referenced to the tree
but you delete the tree so but your leaf
nodes reference still to the tree so
that's said
they're like they exist but they're not
part of that dome but they are complying
the memory they are detached
so in this case we can see we don't have
those detached node at least so which is
good
right and here once you click on it you
can get the details
right for example for google if we
run such snapshot okay and i just
refresh it i can
click here around on the things and same
with this
the other options also kind of uh this
one is also like it
draws a timeline also let it let it run
and plus you can filter from here you
can see the
objects are located this summary is like
you can see statistics
for example how much of it is chords
strings areas
so typically system objects how much of
each memory is being used
let it run
so now let's see
uh dom that has dom docker list you see
this so we have
there around we see that there is some
there are some iframe elements for which
we can have a detached option which
exists
right and you can click and find it
so i believe we have covered most of
these uh
important very important tabs and rest
all for example
uh you can keep using them
right whenever you you know you can
refer them whenever you need whatever
network relations rendering
right so so that's how normally uh
our our journey of uh
com developer tools or console comes to
an end
before that one more thing is if you
want to run some commands for example
you want to
show console so you can directly show
console and it moves forward
so this is like a command from which you
can use thank you so much for watching
thank you everyone for making to the end
of this course and i hope
you learned something new something more
out of this course feel free to provide
your feedback
ratings and happy to share it with your
friends
uh what is the next so the what is next
is that
this is like a chrome we are into prompt
so we might actually
look into how do we develop an extension
or is it possible to develop extra tab
our own one for example you see these
right you might have a course on it so
maybe you can also explore
and once again thanks for watching keep
sharing
keep learning bye bye take care stay
safe